residents of Montecito California are
being told to stay out of town today as
emergency crews turn off gas and power
to fix the damage caused by deadly
mudslides the death toll there has
climbed to 18 as rescue crews expand
their search for at least seven missing
people including a toddler workers are
now trying to clear heavy mud and debris
as new cell phone video emerges showing
the river of mud and water flooding the
first floor of this home the morning of
the storm and then racing down the
street Carter Evans reports from
Montecito hardier good morning good
morning state officials say there are
now more than 1,200 workers using heavy
equipment canines and even drones to aid
in the search and cleanup effort in
ravaged neighborhoods like this it now
looks more like a riverbed with boulders
and debris than a community many of the
beautiful homes that once line this
street are now unrecognizable
what they were afraid of is exactly
happening this cell phone video captures
the moment a deluge of mud inundated the
first floor of Billy Grogan burgers
Montecito home we have his head and
water starts coming through that and
right after that we see a car come
through that hedge now open up the flood
gates and we could see to the left that
our neighbor's house was completely gone
that's where you know heart just kind of
stopped you realized it was serious I
knew it was serious but that's where you
just knew that his family survived but
the lower level of his home is caked in
mud and littered with debris we lost
some of our best family friends and you
know all these other families are going
through it's you know we're lucky but
it's just hard to think about how lucky
we are when they are not so lucky
the Grogan burgers and many other
families could be out of their homes for
weeks as search crews comb the
neighborhoods for signs of life
Doug Vanna warden and his dog Sadie are
with Orange County fire he smells a the
scent of life like human being and she
barks at that focused bark at that one
point to let us know that somebody's
buried there which is great for a team
because it allows us to focus in on
specific areas as opposed to just the
widespread instructions going on down
here hundreds of buildings in the
disaster zone are damaged and covered in
thick
sludge vanna boredom remains positive
even as the window to find survivors
narrows what are your hopes of still
finding someone alive you know what you
never give up hope
I mean why give up hope I mean there's
people down there who are hoping I mean
what right do I have to give up hope
crews are still working to clear the
usually busy 101 freeway but it's taking
a lot longer than expected it was
originally supposed to reopen on Monday
now there is no timeline on when that
will happen
Anthony Carter Evans in Montecito
California thing